SPEAKER: Google Cloud
Platform Managed Instance
Groups are an easy way to set
up a group of identical servers,
for example web front ends.
It can auto-scale and
auto-heal if desired.
To set up a Managed
Instance Group,
start at the Compute Engine
section of the web console.
Click Instance Groups, and
then Create Instance Group.
Name your group and select
single or multi-zone.
Now select a zone or region
and pick the instance template,
or create a new template.
I want an auto-scaling group,
so I select Auto-scaling
and set the min
and max instances
in the auto-scaling metric.
If you'd like the group
to be auto-healing,
set up a health check.
Now click Create.
Now you have a group of
instances that will auto-scale
and auto-heal as needed.